entonces si estamos ante un momento muy
importante pero también hay que tener
cautela y un informe de la comisión de
la verdad no va a solucionar los
problemas que tenemos en materia de
violencias organizadas de violencias
políticas sino que abre un nuevo
escenario para que desde los distintos
lugares en los cuales nos ubicamos
construyamos la reconciliación entonces
este es un paso un impulso muy
importante y como bien lo planteaba
nadie están unas condiciones favorables
para continuar el proceso de
implementación del acuerdo de paz desde
el ámbito político y por supuesto
vendrán unas resistencias claras que ya
se han venido pronunciando